- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance est ouverte.
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
Je souhaite, en votre nom à tous,
féliciter chaleureusement notre XV
Parlementaire et notre capitaine,
Pierre Cazeneuve, et son
président.
Nos joueurs ont porté haut les
couleurs de notre Assemblée lors
de cette Coupe du Monde de rugby
parlementaire, en se hissant sur
la troisième marche du podium.
Ce sont aussi les belles valeurs
du rugby, le sens du collectif et
le respect de l'adversaire, qu'ils
ont fait briller.
Autant de valeurs qui, je n'en
doute pas, sauront inspirer chacun
en cette nouvelle année
parlementaire.
Avant de clore cette parenthèse,
permettez-moi d'adresser, là aussi
en notre nom à tous des voeux de
bon rétablissement au capital de
notre équipe de France, Antoine
Dupont, que nous espérons
retrouver très vite sur le terrain
jusqu'au bout de la compétition!
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par monsieur Vincent
Descoeur, pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Vincent Descoeur: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre.
Les prix des carburants flambent à
la pompe et mettent à mal le
pouvoir d'achat des Français dans
un contexte d'inflation
persistant.
Ils atteignent des niveaux
records: deux euros le litre, et
jusqu'à
2,10 euros dans des stations de
départements ruraux, comme le
Cantal.
La cacophonie a gagné le sommet de
l'Etat.
Après avoir rejeté toute idée
d'intervention, vous avez lancé un
appel désespéré à la générosité
des gros distributeurs.
Une proposition de vente à perte
improvisée, qui s'est heurtée à un
refus catégorique.
Un camouflet qui se double d'un
désavoeu avec la dernière
proposition en date du président
de la République: le retour d'un
chèque carburant.
Vous connaissez notre opposition à
ce dispositif, source
d'inégalités, qui n'a concerné
qu'un peu plus de 4 millions de
foyers, ce qui est bien peu au
regard des 40 millions
d'automobilistes.
Les parents qui conduisent leurs
enfants à l'école, les retraités,
les artisans, petites entreprises,
les professions libérales comme
les infirmières, qui seront exclus
de ce dispositif, n'ont pas
l'impression de faire des
déplacements de confort, pour
reprendre l'expression du
président de la République.
Notre président de groupe, Olivier
Marleix, nous a demandé
d'organiser une conférence sur les
prix de l'énergie, comme le
pétrole et le gaz.
Une proposition à laquelle vous
sembliez souscrire.
Comptez-vous accéder à sa demande?
Pour répondre à cette crise,
allez-vous revoir la fiscalité sur
les carburants et décider d'une
baisse des taxes,
qui représentent plus de la moitié
du prix à la pompe?
Des taxes, Edouard Philippe
s'était empressé d'augmenter, en
son temps, avec les conséquences
sociales qu'on a tous à l'esprit.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire, ministre de l'Economie, des
Finances et de la Souveraineté
industrielle et numérique.
- Bruno Le Maire: Monsieur le
député Vincent Descoeur, nous
connaissons la position de votre
groupe sur les carburants.
C'est soit de baisser la TVA sur
les carburants, qui coûterait 10
milliards d'euros, soit une remise
à la pompe, qui coûterait 12
milliards d'euros par an.
Vous ne pouvez pas nous réclamer
de baisser la dette de la France
et nous obliger à engager 10
milliards d'euros supplémentaires
sur une énergie que nous
produisons pas.
La politique a été menée en France
depuis le début.
Nous taxons lourdement une énergie
que nous ne produisons pas pour
financer une énergie que nous
produisons, l'énergie nucléaire.
Nous garderons cette politique.
Baisser les taxes sur les
carburants, c'est une triple
aberration.
C'est une aberration écologique,
car c'est financer le fossile.
C'est une aberration budgétaire,
car ça creuse le trou de la dette
de l'Etat.
C'est une aberration géopolitique,
parce que l'argent va tout droit
dans la poche de monsieur Poutine.
Nous avons d'autres propositions.
Nous allons les mettre en oeuvre.
Nous avons obtenu de Total qu'il
plafonne les prix des carburants à
1,99 euro.
Nous voulons mettre en place des
prix coûtants à la pompe dans
chacun des magasins de la
distribution.
Nous mettrons en place une
indemnité carburant transport, sur
laquelle vous devriez nous
rejoindre.
Vous voulez aider ceux qui
travaillent.
Nous apportons une aide à ceux qui
travaillent et pas à ceux qui
prennent leur 4x4 pour se rendre
en vacances.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur Descoeur?
- Vincent Descoeur: Monsieur le
ministre, les Français attendent
une réponse immédiate à l'horizon
2024.
Une réponse pour tous ceux qui
travaillent et tous ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se passer de leur
véhicule.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur le président Maillard
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Sylvain Maillard: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, le
réchauffement climatique appelle
la mobilisation de toutes et tous.
Dans ce combat commun, la France
se doit d'être à l'avant-garde.
Depuis 2017, beaucoup a été fait.
Rien que cette année, notre
majorité a voté pour relancer la
filière nucléaire, accélérer le
développement des énergies
renouvelables et pour miser sur
les technologies de demain.
Aucune majorité n'a fait autant
pour l'écologie que celle qui est
assis ici depuis six ans sur ces
bancs.
Il faut que nous accélérions.
Le défi est immense.
L'atteinte de la neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 est notre
objectif.
Madame la Première ministre, à
travers la planification
écologique, dont vous avez la
charge attend des actes forts.
Elle doit être irréversible et
mettre à contribution l'ensemble
des secteurs.
La clé de notre réussite
collective, c'est la production
massive d'énergie décarbonée.
C'est l'accélération de la
rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments et la construction de
nouvelles infrastructures de
transport.
C'est la reconquête de notre
souveraineté alimentaire.
Le projet de loi de finances qui
sera examiné par l'Assemblée
nationale cet automne doit aussi
servir cette ambition écologique.
Ayons comme impératif de mettre en
oeuvre une écologie de progrès, de
solutions basées sur l'innovation
et les incitations.
Non une écologie punitive basée
sur la décroissance!
La loi de production d'énergie
annoncée par le président de la
République s'inscrit dans cette
perspective.
Tout comme la programmation
pluriannuelle des financements de
la transition écologique proposée
par mon groupe.
Madame la Première ministre, quels
seront les prochains jalons que
votre gouvernement entend mettre
en oeuvre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le président Maillard,
vous l'avez dit, l'urgence est là.
Elle est incontestable.
C'est pourquoi le président de la
République a décidé d'agir avec
force depuis six ans.
Depuis 2019, chaque année, nous
faisons mieux que nos objectifs en
termes de baisse d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre.
Aujourd'hui, notre engagement est
connu.
Nous devons réduire nos émissions
de 55% d'ici 2030.
Pour cela, il faut accélérer, car
nous devons faire autant en sept
ans que ce que nous avons fait en
33 ans.
Pour y parvenir,
dès la campagne électorale, le
président de la République
apportait une idée inédite: la
planification écologique, dont il
m'a confié la charge.
Après plus d'un an de travail,
notamment avec les ministres
Christophe Béchu, Agnès
Pannier-Runacher, Marc Fesneau et
Roland Lescure, nous avons
désormais un plan, secteur par
secteur, dont le président de la
République a présenté hier les
grands enjeux.
Comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
souligner auprès des chefs de
parti et des membres du CNR, c'est
d'abord un plan de souveraineté.
Il va nous permettre de sortir de
notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles, notamment du charbon,
d'ici 2027, et de continuer la
réindustrialisation verte de la
France.
C'est un plan de croissance
vertueuse.
Alors que la décroissance nous
priverait des ressources presque
pour financer notre modèle social,
notre plan nous donne les moyens
d'investir et d'innover.
C'est un plan qui ne laisse
personne dans l'impasse.
Nous allons accompagner tous les
Français, offrir des solutions
alternatives décarbonées,
accessibles à tous.
Je pense à l'offre de leasing à
100 euros par mois pour accéder à
un véhicule propre, fabriqué en
Europe.
La planification écologique, c'est
la radicalité des résultats sur la
brutalité des mesures.
C'est une répartition efficace et
équitable de l'effort.
Ce plan, c'est d'abord un plan
pour les territoires.
Dans les prochains jours, les
ministres iront à la rencontre des
élus, région par région, pour
adapter notre planification
écologique à la réalité des
territoires.
Ce plan, c'est du concret.
C'est une accélération de la
rénovation des logements et des
bâtiments publics.
C'est 1 million de pompes à
chaleur fabriquées en France d'ici
2027.
C'est la décarbonation des 50
sites industriels les plus
émetteurs.
C'est un plan financé.
Dès l'année prochaine, nous
investirons 7 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires pour la transition
écologique.
Monsieur le président Sylvain
Maillard, je connais votre
investissement, celui de votre
groupe ainsi que celui de toute la
majorité en faveur de la
transition écologique.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons un plan
ambitieux et crédible.
Avec vous et tous les territoires,
avec ceux qui veulent agir pour la
biodiversité, nous sommes prêts à
le mettre en oeuvre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la Première
ministre.
La parole est à madame Aurélie
Trouvé, pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Aurélie Trouvé: Madame la
présidente, chers collègues,
monsieur le ministre Bruno Le
Maire, vous avez affirmé qu'il n'y
a pas d'appauvrissement de la
société française.
Est-ce à dire que les centaines de
milliers de personnes qui doivent
sauter des repas n'existent pas,
pour vous?
C'est maintenant le cas d'une
personne sur trois, dans ce pays.
Est-ce à dire que toutes celles
qui sont dans les files de l'aide
alimentaire n'existent pas, pour
vous?
Nos concitoyens ont faim et ils
auront froid dans quelques
semaines, faute de pouvoir payer
le chauffage.
Vous êtes enfermé dans votre
extrême libéralisme.
Vous voulez ne rien faire.
Comme il faut occuper l'espace,
vous faites n'importe quoi.
Vous sortez la revente à perte,
une ineptie totale, qui a coalisé
tous les acteurs économiques
contre vous.
Chapeau!
Le président a reculé et a annoncé
d'autres gadgets tout à fait
inutiles, comme le chèque
carburant et la vente à prix
coûtant.
Vous faites n'importe quoi, parce
qu'au fond, vous refusez de vous
en prendre aux riches et aux
multinationales que vous servez
depuis le début.
Grâce à vous, les marges des
grands pétroliers et des
multinationales de
l'agroalimentaire n'ont jamais été
aussi élevées dans les
statistiques.
Ce sont bien ces marges qui font
monter les profits des
actionnaires, mais aussi les prix
de l'essence de l'alimentation.
Le président Macron nous annonce
maintenant un accord de modération
des marges.
Ca fait des mois que vous suppliez
et que vous quémandez auprès des
multinationales.
Vous savez qu'elles ne font que
nourrir les dividendes.
Quelle comédie!
Ce serait drôle si ce n'était pas
dramatique pour nos concitoyens.
Allez-vous bloquer les prix des
carburants en sortie de
raffinerie?
Tout cela est parfaitement
possible et vous le savez.
A moins que vous ne vouliez rester
dans l'histoire que le
gouvernement qui a ramené la
France à l'état d'un pays qui a
faim?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Bruno Le Maire,
ministre de l'Economie.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
députée Aurélie Trouvé, je ne sais
pas si nous faisons n'importe
quoi, mais vous, vous ne faites
rien.
Si vous aviez tant d'attachement
au pouvoir d'achat des ménages,
pourquoi vous n'avez pas voté le
bouclier tarifaire sur le prix du
gaz?
Pourquoi vous n'avez pas voté le
bouclier tarifaire pour
l'électricité?
Pourquoi vous n'avez pas voté la
revalorisation du RSA?
Pourquoi vous n'avez pas voté
l'indemnité carburant transport?
Vous refusez tout ce qui peut
aider le pouvoir d'achat en France
par position idéologique vis-à-vis
de cette majorité.
Voilà la réalité politique, madame
la députée.
Il est toujours temps de vous
convertir.
Dans quelques semaines, le
parlement va examiner le projet de
loi de finances pour 2024.
Il comporte une revalorisation de
tous les minima sociaux.
La voterez-vous?
Il comporte une revalorisation de
5,2% pour les retraites.
Le voterez-vous?
Il comportera 10 milliards d'euros
d'aides pour payer la facture
d'électricité des ménages
français.
La voterez-vous?
Il comportera une indemnité
carburant transport, qui permet de
réduire de 0,20 euros par litre le
coût du carburant pour ceux qui
travaillent.
La voterez-vous?
Oui ou non?
Un peu de cohérence.
Votre attachement au pouvoir
d'achat des ménages est de pure
façade.
La réalité, c'est que, par pure
idéologie, vous refusez de voter
nos mesures.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur le
président André Chassaigne, pour
le groupe GDR.
- André Chassaigne: Madame la
présidente, madame la Première
ministre, la situation sociale de
notre pays a atteint un seuil
d'alerte sans pareille.
Elle est explosive.
Malgré cela, le président de la
République a une nouvelle fois
versé dans l'auto-satisfecit.
Il nous explique que cela pourrait
être pire.
Dans le même temps, Bruno Le
Maire, en ministre, en arrive à
quémander des efforts aux uns et
aux autres.
Vous tremblez à l'idée de
contraindre.
L'urgence est pourtant sous vos
yeux.
40% des étudiants déclarent
renoncer à des soins.
40% des Français au SMIC se
privent de repas.
Près d'un enfant sur cinq est
touché par la pauvreté.
Plus violente encore est la
situation subie par les habitants
des territoires dits d'outre-mer,
allant pour certains à être privés
du droit fondamental à l'eau
potable.
Demi-mesure, impréparation, voilà
vos seules réponses à la
stagnation des revenus.
Vous méprisez le parlement.
Vous maltraitez notre démocratie.
Vous matez la colère plutôt que de
l'entendre.
Vous vous êtes coupés du peuple.
Nos propositions sont sur la
table.
Elles sont largement soutenues
dans tout le pays.
Indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation, augmentation des
pensions, blocage des prix des
biens de première nécessité,
sortie du marché européen de
l'énergie, taxation des
superprofits.
Nous les porterons aux côtés de
l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales, le 13 octobre
prochain.
Comme l'a rappelé mon collègue
Fabien Roussel, la question
sociale, celle de la vie chère,
est la question centrale.
N'ajoutez pas de la colère au
désespoir.
Agissez.
Agissez avant une nouvelle
explosion sociale.
Entendrez-vous enfin nos
propositions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président André Chassaigne, je
suis bien consciente des
difficultés que rencontrent
certains de nos concitoyens dans
l'Hexagone comme dans les
outre-mer, face à l'inflation qui
dure depuis plusieurs mois.
J'ai une conviction: la solution
durable pour le pouvoir d'achat,
c'est l'emploi.
Cette conviction, c'est celle de
mon gouvernement.
Je sais qu'elle est largement
partagée sur les bancs de cet
hémicycle, y compris dans votre
groupe.
Depuis six ans, nous menons des
réformes courageuses qui donnent
des résultats.
2 millions d'emplois ont été
créés.
Des usines ouvrent à nouveau.
Le taux de chômage est au plus
bas, depuis 40 ans.
Aujourd'hui, nous gardons le cap,
car cette politique économique
produit des résultats.
Je suis d'accord avec vous,
monsieur le président Chassaigne,
certaines situations restent
choquantes et il faut que le
travail paye mieux.
Je pense notamment au temps
partiel subi, à certains métiers
essentiels encore sous-payés, les
caissières, les agents
d'entretien...
Il est intolérable que certains
soient condamnés à passer
l'ensemble de leur vie
professionnelle au SMIC sans
aucune perspective de carrière.
Ces questions seront au coeur de
la conférence sociale, que je
réunirai avec Olivier Dussopt, le
16 octobre.
J'ajoute que nous agissons pour le
pouvoir d'achat de tous depuis le
début de cette période
d'inflation, avec les bouclier
tarifaires, la revalorisation des
petites retraites, et je note
qu'aucune de ces mesures n'a été
votée par votre groupe.
Cet effort financier exceptionnel,
nous l'avons porté en
responsabilité et en demandant à
tous les acteurs de prendre leur
part.
C'est notamment le sens cette
année de la taxation des rentes
des énergéticiens.
Vous m'interrogez sur la situation
de nos concitoyens des outre-mer.
C'est le coeur des mesures
structurelles que j'ai annoncées
le 18 juillet dernier, à l'issue
du comité interministériel des
outre-mer.
Des mesures pour le prix des
carburants vont être instaurées.
Nous agissons concrètement pour
nos compatriotes ultramarins face
à la vie chère.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame la Première
ministre.
La parole est à monsieur le
président Pancher pour le groupe
LIOT.
- Bertrand Pancher: Beaucoup de
nos compatriotes souffrent.
Inflation alimentaire, coût de la
rentrée, hausse des carburants...
Neuf millions de Français sont en
situation de privation matérielle,
selon une étude de l'INSEE.
40% des plus précaires auraient
supprimé un repas.
Il est urgent d'agir pour les
aider.
Nous entendons des situations de
détresse chaque jour dans nos
permanences.
Les associations d'aides
alimentaires nous alertent.
Elles sont débordées.
La semaine dernière, nous vous
avons fait plusieurs propositions,
dont un chèque carburant,
immédiat, pour les ménages
modestes et les classes moyennes
contraintes d'utiliser leur
voiture.
Le président vient de reprendre
notre idée.
C'est bien, mais le compte n'y est
pas.
Il y a trop d'oubliés.
Moins de 5 millions de personnes
sont concernées.
Le montant reste trop modeste.
100 euros.
Il faut davantage.
C'est plutôt à 10 millions de
Français qu'il faudrait l'envoyer.
L'énorme inflation de produits
alimentaires augmente la pauvreté.
Une aide ciblée fut promise par le
président, puis fut enterrée à de
nombreuses reprises.
Nous demandons la mise en place
immédiate du chèque alimentaire
pour les ménages les plus
modestes.
Quand allez-vous le mettre en
place?
Il faut penser à notre jeunesse et
remettre le repas à 1 euro dans
les cantines.
Pour financer ces mesures, le
groupe LIOT a proposé des
économies, comme la baisse des
dépenses pour les cabinets de
conseil, à l'instar de McKinsey.
Il y a aussi l'augmentation des
taxes sur les superprofits.
Madame la Première ministre,
quelles nouvelles mesures
allez-vous prendre en urgence pour
aider nos concitoyens qui
souffrent?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
député Bertrand Pancher, je le
redis, je mesure pleinement les
difficultés de certains de nos
concitoyens face à une inflation
forte depuis plusieurs mois,
notamment sur les prix
alimentaires.
Il y a des difficultés dans
l'Hexagone comme dans les
outre-mer.
Les Français sont confrontés à la
vie chère.
Dans ce contexte, monsieur le
président,
mon gouvernement a protégé
plus qu'aucun autre gouvernement
en Europe.
Je pense au bouclier tarifaire,
qui a limité la hausse des prix de
gaz et d'électricité.
A la remise carburant et à
l'indemnité carburant.
Je pense aussi à la revalorisation
des petites retraites qui entrent
en vigueur à partir de ce mois-ci
et qui permettront à 1,7 million
de nos concitoyens de toucher en
moyenne 600 euros supplémentaire
par an.
Je pense enfin à l'indexation sur
l'inflation de toutes les
prestations sociales et des
retraites, qui sera reconduite en
2024.
Cela représente un effort de 20
milliards d'euros l'année
prochaine.
Monsieur le président Bertrand
Pancher, face aux difficultés des
Français, nous allons continuer à
agir.
Comme annoncé par le président de
la République, nous reconduiront
l'indemnité carburant pour les
Français qui travaillent et qui
ont besoin de leur voiture.
C'est une aide de 100 euros qui
accompagnera les plus modestes.
C'est l'équivalent d'une remise de
0,20 euro par litre.
Vous m'interrogez sur les
étudiants.
Je rappelle que nous prolongeons
les repas à 1 euro pour les
étudiants boursiers, tous les
étudiants en difficulté.
Nous aurons doublé le montant des
aides aux banques alimentaires en
2023, par rapport à 2021.
Nous allons augmenter le fonds
alimentation durable pour
permettre à chacun d'accéder à une
alimentation de qualité.
Dans ce contexte, chacun doit
prendre sa part.
Nous devons utiliser tous les
leviers à notre disposition.
C'est pourquoi je réunirai tout à
l'heure tous les acteurs de la
filière de carburant.
Ils savent que nous attendons de
leur part une mobilisation
exceptionnelle à la hauteur de
l'enjeu.
Je leur passerai des messages
simples, comme baisser les prix,
faire plus de transparence sur les
marges et aider les Français à
trouver les meilleurs prix près de
chez eux.
Face à l'inflation, mon
gouvernement agit.
Chacun doit prendre sa part.
Je sais pouvoir compter sur votre
soutien pour le pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Cyrille
Isaac-Sibille pour le groupe
démocrate.
- Cyrille Isaac-Sibille: Ma
question s'adresse à la ministre
de la Prévention et de la Santé.
Toutes les politiques publiques
partagent leur vision de leur
action au moyen de débats sur leur
stratégie.
Pour la santé, lors de la dernière
législature, nous avions un cap,
Ma santé 2022.
Aujourd'hui, les parlementaires
ont besoin de connaître votre
vision.
Vos services travaillent
actuellement sur un document qui
définit la trajectoire
pluriannuelle de la politique de
santé.
Ce document s'appelle la
"stratégie nationale de santé".
Dans ce document, une place
importante est faite à la
prévention.
C'est pourquoi nous saluons
l'annonce de mesures phares du
prochain PLFSS.
La vaccination généralisée et le
traitement préventif contre la
bronchiolite.
Pour qu'une politique de
prévention soit efficace, nous
devons concentrer nos efforts sur
quelques priorités.
Il y a le surpoids et la santé
mentale.
Beaucoup de propositions
intéressantes figurent dans cette
stratégie nationale de santé.
Je conseille à tous mes collègues
d'en prendre connaissance.
Il y en a une que j'ai défendue:
la création d'un brevet de santé
publique et la formation de
300.000 secouristes en santé
mentale.
Monsieur le ministre, ma question
est la suivante: pouvez-vous nous
proposer au titre de l'article
50-1 de la Constitution, un débat
devant le Parlement, exposant la
stratégie nationale de santé?
Un débat essentiel pour tous les
acteurs de la santé, un débat en
amont du PLFSS, nous permettant de
connaître votre vision, vos
objectifs, vos priorités, afin de
d'éclairer le débat budgétaire que
nous allons bientôt avoir.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Aurélien Rousseau,
ministre de la Santé et de la
Prévention.
- Aurélien Rousseau: Monsieur le
député, vous avez raison, nous
avons besoin d'une stratégie de
santé pluriannuelle évaluée, une
stratégie de santé qui soit
débattue régulièrement devant le
Parlement.
Nous avons besoin de la replacer
dans un cadre politique.
Il ne faut pas que ce soit
simplement des indicateurs et des
chiffres.
Ce cadre politique est d'autant
plus important que nous avons
aujourd'hui trois grands
changements.
Vous l'avez cité, c'est Ma santé
2022.
De très nombreuses initiatives ont
été prises, depuis.
Il y a eu la rémunération des
soignants.
Nous avons aussi la crise du
Covid, qui nous a fait progresser
sur de très nombreux chantiers.
La deuxième raison pour laquelle
nous devons avoir ce débat, c'est
que le virage préventif est en
cours.
Il est pris.
Vous avez cité la campagne
d'immunisation contre la
bronchiolite.
Cette campagne est une réussite.
Nous en sommes à 80% d'adhésion
dans les maternités.
Vous avez cité le sujet de la
santé mentale, qui est majeur, le
sujet du sport santé.
Oui, nous devons avancer sur ce
débat politique.
Nous le devons d'autant plus que
les soignants ont besoin de savoir
quel est notre plan.
Les années à venir vont encore
être difficiles, mais nous avons
les ressources pour y répondre.
Nous devons ce débat et cette
clarté aux soignants et aux
Français.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Alexandre Loubet, pour
le Rassemblement National.
- Alexandre Loubet: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre, Elisabeth Borne.
Des dizaines de milliers de
clandestins débarquent sur les
côtes européennes, comme à
Lampedusa.
Cette immigration massive coûte 2
milliards d'euros pour le
contribuable.
Elle aggrave notre insécurité et
menace notre identité.
Alors que les Français attendent
de la fermeté contre l'immigration
clandestine, vous préférez
l'encourager.
Vous préférez l'encourager en
refusant d'examiner les demandes
d'asile dans les pays d'origine,
en refusant de supprimer le droit
du sol ou l'aide médicale d'Etat,
ou encore en refusant de contrôler
nos frontières européennes et
nationales.
Vous n'exécutez que 7% des
expulsions.
Vous allez régulariser les
clandestins dans les métiers en
tension.
Vous soutenez le pacte européen
des migrations, -- qui permettra à
la Commission européenne d'imposer
des migrants à la France, sous
peine d'amende.
D'ici 2050, la population
africaine va doubler.
Elle atteindra 2,5 milliards de
personnes.
Face à cette bombe démographique,
si nous ne voulons pas que la
France et l'Europe disparaissent,
nous devons mettre un terme au
laxisme migratoire, pour défendre
nos frontières.
Qu'attendez-vous pour soutenir le
blocus maritime demandé par
l'Italie?
Qu'attendez-vous pour stopper
cette immersion et dissuader
l'arrivée de migrants en France?
Qu'attendez-vous pour agir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député, s'il y a bien quelque
chose que nous avons appris,
depuis plusieurs mois, c'est que
les campagnes électorales
démagogiques pour ceux qui
voulaient le Brexit, ce sont des
campagnes qui mentent aux
Européens!
Vous auriez pu profiter de votre
question pour vous excuser.
Vous avez signifié des
contrevérités.
Pourquoi, monsieur le député, si
le pacte migratoire était si
mauvais, monsieur Salvini et
madame Meloni l'ont-ils soutenu?
Vous êtes totalement
schizophrénique.
Vous refusez que nous réglions les
problèmes.
Les contrôles aux frontières
européennes, c'est une proposition
du président de la République que
vos députés ont refusé au
Parlement européen.
L'enregistrement des étrangers aux
frontières de l'Europe, c'est une
proposition que vous avez refusée
au Parlement européen.
Si nous ne proposons pas les
frontières européennes c'est à
cause du Rassemblement National.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
Monsieur Alexandre Loubet?
- Alexandre Loubet: Quand on veut,
on peut.
Notre allié, Matteo Salvini,
lorsqu'il était ministre de
l'Intérieur a réussi à baisser de
près de 80% l'arrivée des migrants
sur le sol italien.
Si vous êtes si fiers de votre
bilan, pourquoi ne voulez-vous pas
consulter les Français par
référendum?
La réalité, c'est que les Français
désapprouvent votre politique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur?
- Gérald Darmanin: Vous pouvez
courir après la démagogie de
Marion Maréchal-Le Pen, mais ne
faites pas la campagne européenne
de l'extrême droite sur le dos des
Français.
La vérité, c'est que vous ne savez
pas quoi dire devant la défaite
idéologique de ceux qui mentent au
peuple lorsqu'ils se présentent
aux élections.
La vérité, c'est que la solution
est européenne.
Vous appelez la Commission
européenne quand il y a des
problèmes.
Vous courez après la démagogie.
Vous espérez que le beau temps
joue pour vous.
Grâce aux gendarmes français et
grâce à ce que va faire l'Europe,
nous vous faisons mentir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Brun, pour le groupe socialiste.
- Philippe Brun: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
Première ministre.
Madame la Première ministre, nos
artisans-boulangers sont en deuil
alors qu'ils viennent de perdre
l'un des leurs à Marseille.
Un boulanger a effectivement mis
fin à ses jours, comme tant
d'autres avant lui, comme 25% de
nos artisans qui déclarent
aujourd'hui réfléchir et penser au
suicide, quand 40% d'entre eux
avouent avoir déjà pensé passer à
l'acte.
La situation aujourd'hui de nos
boulanger et de nos artisans est
absolument catastrophique.
Ils sont pris à la gorge par
l'explosion des prix de l'énergie,
en particulier l'explosion des
prix de l'électricité, que vous
n'arrivez pas à juguler.
Comment justifier qu'aujourd'hui,
notre pays produise l'énergie à 60
euros du mégawattheure?
EDF la vend à 42 euros à ses
concurrents.
Nos boulangers la payent à 700
euros du mégawatt/heure.
C'est un pillage organisé, madame
la Première ministre.
Nous avons voté ici souverainement
à l'Assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi pour mettre fin
à ce chaos énergétique.
Elle a été adoptée deux fois par
l'Assemblée nationale et une fois
par le Sénat.
Elle sera bientôt examinée.
Madame la Première ministre, alors
que le président de la République
a annoncé au Conseil national de
la refondation vouloir rétablir un
prix de l'électricité conforme à
60 euros du mégawattheure, est-ce
que, cette fois-ci, enfin, le
gouvernement soutiendra notre
proposition de loi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire, ministre des Petites et
Moyennes entreprises.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Brun, je
souhaiterais d'abord au nom du
gouvernement, et je n'en doute
pas, au nom de la représentation
nationale, avoir un mot de soutien
à l'endroit du boulanger qui a mis
fin à ses jours, mais aussi à ses
proches, son meilleur ami et à
tout son entourage.
Je vous réponds avec sincérité,
j'ai appelé le préfet ce matin,
les services de la Direction
générale des finances publiques
aussi.
Je connais l'honneur du Parti
Socialiste, de ses membres et des
politiques en général.
Je sais qu'on ne mélangera pas
tout.
Je sais que vous ne ferez pas de
récupération politique là-dessus.
Le commerce de ce boulanger
n'avait pas de difficultés en
matière d'énergie.
J'ai vérifié l'intégralité des
dettes fiscales, sociales, mais
aussi sa situation auprès des
fournisseurs et je sais qu'on peut
compter sur le soutien entier de
la représentation nationale à
l'endroit de cet homme qui s'est
donné la mort hier.
Ce qui est indécent, c'est la
récupération politique.
Ce qui est indécent, c'est de tout
mélanger et ce qui est indécent,
c'est de lier des choses qui n'ont
pas à être liées.
Certains députés de votre groupe,
madame Panot, puisque ça s'est
passé dans votre circonscription,
si l'origine de ce drame vous
intéresse, écoutez-moi.
Pour ce qui est du prix de
l'énergie, nous voulons protéger
nos petites entreprises.
Nous continuerons à le faire.
Face aux drames humains, les
vociférations ne font pas le
poids, madame Panot.
Il faut respecter la mémoire de
cet homme qui s'est donné la mort.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Brun.
- Philippe Brun: Madame la
secrétaire d'Etat, vos diversions
ne trompent personne.
Des boulangers viennent nous voir
tous les jours avec des factures
de 5000 ou 10.000 euros, des
factures qui ont été multipliées
par 14.
Le Sénat jouera contre vous, votre
indifférence et votre impuissance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Anne-Laurence Petel.
- Anne-Laurence Petel: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères.
Pour les Arméniens, l'histoire
semble un éternel recommencement.
Après le blocus et la famine sont
venues les bombes.
Vient aujourd'hui l'exode pour
échapper au massacre.
Voilà le sort des Arméniens du
Haut-Karabakh.
Ils sont assiégés depuis 10 mois
par l'Azerbaïdjan.
Ils ne mangent qu'un repas par
jour.
Ils ont subi l'assaut des soldats
et bombardements azéris ces
derniers jours.
Malgré les efforts diplomatiques
de la France et des Etats-Unis
auxquels s'est jointe l'Allemagne,
une haine ancestrale pour le
Haut-Karabakh est de mise.
La République d'Arménie, qui
s'apprête à accueillir des
dizaines de milliers de réfugiés,
doit faire face à une tentative de
déstabilisation interne.
Cette jeune démocratie est en
danger.
Emmanuel Macron a réaffirmé son
soutien inconditionnel aux
Arméniens et il a rappelé sa
vigilance absolue au respect de
l'intégrité territoriale du pays.
La communauté internationale doit
être lucide, les promesses d'un
tyran sont des leurres.
Ce sont des stratégies pour gagner
du temps.
L'Azerbaïdjan, avec le soutien de
la Turquie et la complicité de la
Russie, a lancé une guerre de
conquête dans le Caucase du Sud.
Que peut la diplomatie face à un
tyran qui ne comprend que le
rapport de force et piétine le
droit international?
En avril, vous avez vu les
positions azerbaïdjanaises en
territoire arménien.
Il nous faut agir sans délai.
La France doit prendre
l'initiative d'une action
humanitaire d'ampleur pour aider
l'Arménie à accueillir les
réfugiés.
La France et l'Union Européenne
doivent s'engager dans un ensemble
de sanctions.
Une coopération internationale
doit être déployée pour garantir
la protection des frontières de
l'Arménie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères et de
l'Europe, Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée, vous évoquez un
sujet douloureux.
Je voudrais commencer par dire
notre émotion et notre tristesse
suite à l'explosion intervenue
hier soir.
La France est en contact, à ce
sujet, avec les autorités
arméniennes.
Elle enverra dans les prochaines
heures du matériel d'urgence à
Erevan pour aider au traitement
des blessés les plus graves.
Cet accident dramatique intervient
alors que des milliers d'Arméniens
fuient leurs foyers après
l'intervention militaire
déclenchée par l'Azerbaïdjan le 19
septembre.
Cela fait plus de neuf mois que le
blocus dure.
Il est imposé en violation du
droit international.
Cet incident vient souligner le
caractère grave de ce qui se joue.
Le président de la République l'a
dit.
Ceci se joue sous le regard
complice de la Russie.
La France a aussitôt condamné
cette intervention militaire.
Elle a aussitôt demandé et obtenu
une nouvelle réunion du Conseil de
sécurité et elle demande à
l'Azerbaïdjan de respecter le
droit international, de respecter
ses engagements, le droit des
populations arméniennes à vivre
chez elles en sécurité, dans le
respect de leur histoire et leur
culture.
Nous n'accepterons pas, madame la
députée, que l'aide humanitaire
soit entravée.
Nous nous opposerons à toute
tentative de remise en cause de
l'intégrité territoriale de
l'Arménie.
La France prendra, dans les jours
qui viennent, des initiatives
comme il le faut, que ce soit à
titre national, à titre bilatéral
avec l'Arménie, que ce soit aux
Nations Unies, en qualité de
membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité ou que ce soit au sein de
l'Union Européenne.
Nous porterons aussi à plus de 12
millions d'euros l'aide que nous
apporterons aux réfugiés et
déplacés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Eva Sas.
- Eva Sas: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Chers collègues, monsieur le
ministre de la Transition
écologique, nous attendions depuis
juillet les annonces du président
sur la planification écologique.
Nous attendions un moratoire sur
les projets autoroutiers, à
commencer par l'arrêt du funeste
projet de l'A69.
Nous attendions une loi de
programmation de la transition
écologique comme vous l'avez fait
pour la recherche, la justice et
les armées.
Nous espérions une augmentation de
l'écocontribution sur les billets
d'avion.
Nous avons eu des formules de com'
et une stratégie illisible.
Il n'y a pas de plan.
Il y a des objectifs, mais pas de
moyens.
Il y a une méthode, mais pas de
volonté politique.
Vous ne pouvez pas en même temps
défendre les transports collectifs
et "la bagnole".
Vous ne pouvez pas soutenir le
ferroviaire et céder devant le
lobby aérien.
Vous ne pouvez pas réduire les
moyens des collectivités locales
et leur demander de financer les
RER métropolitains.
Le "en même temps" ne marche pas
en matière écologique.
Vous êtes irresponsables.
Les écologistes ont présenté hier
un plan de la transition
écologique progressif et financé.
Nous avons analysé tous les
rapports que vous avez commandés.
Les constats sont clairs et
convergents: il faut mettre 13
milliards d'euros sur la table dès
2024 et monter à 31 milliards en
2030.
Nous avons proposé une
planification.
Nous prenons nos responsabilités.
Il y a urgence.
Si nous portons aujourd'hui les
"warning stripes", c'est pour
réclamer des aides solennellement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Vous n'avez
pas à porter cette tenue.
Je vous invite à cesser
immédiatement.
Je vous remercie.
Nous avons rappelé ce matin en
conférence des présidents que le
débat devait être respectueux de
nos institutions, des Français et
de nos règles.
Je compte sur chacun d'entre vous
pour respecter ce que nous nous
sommes dit ce matin.
Madame Sas, c'est bon.
Allez-y, terminez votre question.
- Eva Sas: Nous posons une
question simple: quand allez-vous
doter la France d'une grande loi
de programmation de la transition
écologique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, madame Sas.
S'il vous plaît, je vous
demanderais de remettre les
vêtements qui couvraient ce
tee-shirt.
Vous n'avez pas à manifester par
votre habillement une quelconque
opinion dans cet hémicycle.
Huées
Alors...
Je suis contrainte...
Soit vous respectez nos règles,
soit je vous rappelle à l'ordre.
Huées
Je vous remercie.
Je ne veux plus voir cela pendant
la session qui s'ouvre.
Ce règlement s'impose à tous.
Il s'impose à tous.
Je vais donner la parole à
monsieur Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, je comprends que,
pour ne pas parler du fond, vous
choisissiez la forme et un espèce
de happening.
A la vérité, madame Sas, au lieu
de vous réfugier devant des
formules toutes faites, vous
devriez reconnaître le travail qui
a été fait.
On ne peut pas en même temps
critiquer la proposition du
gouvernement et, dans le même
temps, être confronté à la
réalité.
On ne peut pas avoir été, comme
vous, députée de 2012 à 2017 quand
la France a baissé ses émissions
seulement de 1% et voir
qu'aujourd'hui, nous avons plus
que doublé ce rythme de baisse des
émissions.
On ne peut pas continuer à être
dans une posture qui laisse penser
que, pour réussir la transition
écologique dans ce pays, on ne
peut pas être écologiste si on
n'est pas de gauche.
On ne peut pas en même temps taper
sur le nucléaire et expliquer
qu'il faut accélérer la baisse des
émissions.
On ne peut pas à la fois penser
que c'est -- que la seule solution
serait de taxer et d'interdire.
Un an de travail a été proposé
hier, une accélération dans le
domaine de la rénovation, les
transports, dans le domaine de ce
qui a été fait en ce qui concerne
les vélos.
On a montré une stratégie unique
au monde, qu'aucun pays n'a encore
déployé.
C'est une stratégie qui n'a pas
d'équivalent dans les pays où les
écologistes sont en
responsabilité.
L'écologie mérite mieux que des
postures ou des happenings pendant
la séance des questions au
gouvernement.
Elle mérite mieux qu'une
radicalité qui se confondrait à la
brutalité.
Elle mérite de la complexité, elle
nécessite de la nuance.
Elle mérite de prendre des
décisions, de les voter et de les
rendre applicables.
C'est l'honneur de cette majorité.
C'est l'explication qui commencera
à partir de demain dans la phase
de territorialisation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
Merci.
La parole est à madame Agnès Carel
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Agnès Carel: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale.
L'éducation en zones rurales a été
définie comme une priorité par le
président de la République.
Sur ce sujet, nous sommes tous
concernés.
Le gouvernement a annoncé un plan
pour soutenir nos écoles rurales,
plan très attendu par les parents
et les élus.
Deux chiffres sont très parlants.
9 départements sur 10 sont des
départements ruraux.
Un établissement scolaire à deux
fois moins de chances d'être situé
en REP s'il est en zone rurale
plutôt qu'en zone urbaine.
Les élèves des écoles rurales sont
pourtant essentiels pour résorber
la fracture territoriale et
redynamiser nos territoires.
Ne serait-il pas judicieux de
faire bénéficier à ces écoles des
programmes dans les mêmes
conditions que ceux des grandes
villes?
Pourquoi ne pas élargir les aides
à tous les établissements?
Il faudrait établir des critères
sociaux et d'éloignement pour
garantir les mêmes conditions
d'enseignement sur tout le
territoire.
Nous pourrions lancer les assises
de l'éducation prioritaire.
Il faut redéfinir des critères
d'aide et d'accompagnement pour y
inclure les établissements ruraux
qui en ont besoin.
Monsieur le ministre, quelles sont
les dispositions que vous entendez
prendre dans ce domaine?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gabriel
Attal.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée, l'école de la
République, elle ne fait pas de
tri, elle ne fait pas de
hiérarchie.
Elle fait la même promesse à tous
les élèves de France, celle de
bénéficier des mêmes chances pour
réussir, pour voir son niveau
s'élever, pour être en capacité de
construire sa vie.
Oui, ça veut dire qu'il faut
mettre davantage de moyens pour
certaines écoles et certains
territoires.
Evidemment, les quartiers
politique de la ville, mais aussi
les territoires ruraux.
Nous savons que les élèves de ces
territoires rencontrent davantage
de difficultés que les autres.
Vous avez commis un rapport
extrêmement important sur
l'éducation prioritaire.
Nous avons un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été prises.
La Première ministre s'est
particulièrement engagée et a fait
des annonces avant l'été, des
annonces qui seront tenues.
Elle a pris un engagement ferme et
inédit: aucune fermeture de classe
inopinée ou non concertée grâce à
une visibilité sur trois ans.
Nous sommes en train de construire
les modalités qui nous permettront
de garder de la visibilité.
Dans la droite ligne de cette
ambition, nous allons continuer à
augmenter nos moyens pour
conserver un taux d'encadrement
qui est plus élevé que celui que
nous connaissons ailleurs.
Nous allons construire 3000
nouvelles places d'internat
d'excellence qui s'ajouteront aux
8000 places déjà existantes.
Nous allons continuer à renforcer
les moyens des écoles rurales,
notamment celles qui souffrent le
plus d'éloignement et dont les
élèves souffrent le plus de
l'éloignement.
C'est ce que nous allons faire
avec les territoires éducatifs
ruraux qui permettent un
accompagnement pédagogique
éducatif renforcé.
Dans votre département de
Seine-Maritime, c'est 18.500
élèves qui en bénéficient.
Nous allons continuer à mettre en
place des dispositifs ruraux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
Alors...
- Agnès Carel: Merci, monsieur le
ministre.
Vous avez pris en compte beaucoup
de sujets.
Merci à vous.
Nous comptons sur vous pour
résorber les fractures
territoriales.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Il lui restait 11 secondes.
La parole est à madame Angélique
Ranc pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Angélique Ranc: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Chers collègues, monsieur le
ministre de l'Economie, cette
rentrée coûte bien cher aux
Français: 11,3% de hausse des
coûts des fournitures scolaires.
Si seulement cela se cantonnait
aux crayons et aux cahiers.
L'inflation grimpe et le pouvoir
d'achat des Français diminue.
Vous êtes les grands fautifs.
Votre récente proposition montre
la déconnexion totale du
gouvernement.
Les distributeurs l'ont refusée.
Les Français ne le feront pas.
S'ils ne peuvent plus prendre leur
voiture, le train non plus.
Cette rentrée, c'est finalement un
énième confinement pour les
Français, à la seule différence
qu'ils ne craignent plus la Covid,
mais la ruine.
Les tarifs réguliers de
l'électricité ont augmenté de 10%
ce 1er août pour les particuliers,
mais également pour les petits
entreprises.
Les factures ont quand même plus
que doublé depuis 2021 du fait de
votre obstination à accepter le
mode européen de fixation des prix
de l'électricité.
Sans ces règles contraires aux
intérêts de la France, les
Français verraient leurs factures
baisser de 500 euros en moyenne.
Que répondez-vous aux Français qui
manquent en moyenne de 588 euros
pour renouer avec les loisirs et
une vie plus confortable?
A ceux qui ne peuvent plus se
déplacer ni se chauffer, souffler
un peu et construire leur avenir
décemment, ne croyez-vous pas
qu'il soit enfin temps d'écouter
les propositions du Rassemblement
National?
Réformer les règles européennes de
fixation de l'électricité, baisser
la TVA sur les produits de
l'énergie, les produits de
première nécessité ou contrôler
drastiquement les groupes qui font
flamber les prix sous couvert de
l'inflation.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Madame la
députée Ranc, je ne crois
sincèrement pas que les solutions
du Rassemblement National soient
les bonnes contre l'inflation.
L'inflation est tirée par les prix
de l'énergie.
Baisser la TVA sur les prix du
pétrole, c'est tout simplement
alimenter la consommation
d'énergie fossile, faire la
politique des producteurs.
Nous ne sommes pas producteurs de
pétrole.
Votre proposition de baisse de la
TVA sur l'essence, c'est 10
milliards d'euros.
C'est le prix d'un réacteur
nucléaire.
Avec cette majorité, nous
préférons investir dans l'énergie
nucléaire et dans l'indépendance
énergétique du pays que de
financer la politique de
restriction de production des pays
producteurs.
Nous voulons aussi aider ceux qui
travaillent.
Nous allons mettre en place des
indemnités carburant et transport.
Ce sera mis en place et j'espère
que vous voterez cela au 1er
janvier 2024.
Ce sera 100 euros par véhicule.
Ce sera une économie de 0,20 euro
par litre de carburant pour tous
ceux qui travaillent.
Les distributeurs, nous les
recevrons tout à l'heure avec la
Première ministre.
Je suis convaincu qu'ils
s'engageront à offrir de l'essence
à prix coûtant pour les
consommateurs.
Le combat de l'inflation, c'est un
combat de tous les jours.
Il nous mobilise avec tous les
ministres.
Nous obtenons des résultats.
Nous continuons à mener ce combat.
Je ne crois pas aux solutions de
court terme du RN.
Les nôtres visent l'indépendance
énergétique de la nation.
- Angélique Ranc: Monsieur le
ministre, les dispositions en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat, vous
les avez déjà proposées.
Les Français sont toujours dans la
même situation.
Le pouvoir d'achat n'a pas
augmenté.
Si les mouchoirs ne coûtaient pas
aussi cher, j'en utiliserais un
pour pleurer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Anne
Stambach-Terrenoir.
- Anne Stambach-Terrenoir: Merci,
madame la présidente.
L'écologie à la française, une
écologie qui n'est pas dans le
déni, mais qui évacue le sujet de
l'A69.
L'écologie à la française, c'est
une écologie de progrès aussi.
On peut déployer aujourd'hui de
gros dispositifs pour abattre des
arbres centenaires magnifiques,
réserve de biodiversité.
Tout cela au beau milieu de la
nuit devant les larmes de ceux qui
les protégeaient depuis si
longtemps.
L'objectif est de détruire vite
avant que la justice ne puisse se
prononcer sur les recours déposés.
En Haute-Garonne, le 1er
septembre, un homme est entré en
grève de la faim.
Il est totalement impossible de se
faire entendre dans notre pays
face à la destruction du vivant et
l'urgence écologique.
On est face à un mur.
Que faut-il faire?
Ce projet d'autoroute a été pensé
il y a 30 ans.
Il est archaïque et inutile.
Il va détruire près de 400
hectares de terres agricoles,
bétonner les espèces protégées,
assécher des zones humides pour
longer la nationale existante en
espérant gagner quelques minutes.
C'est absurde.
Les scientifiques vous demandent
d'arrêter ce massacre.
Comment oser parler de
planification écologique et
défendre cette aberration?
Monsieur le ministre Clément
Beaune, quand tout sera détruit et
que la terre sera trop sèche pour
abriter la vie, que direz-vous à
nos enfants?
Allez-vous pour une fois
privilégier le vivant aux intérêts
financiers de quelques-uns?
Laisserez-vous Thomas Brail et ses
compagnons de lutte mourir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Clément
Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la présidente, mesdames et
messieurs les députés, madame la
députée, ne vous en déplaise, nous
sommes dans une démocratie et un
Etat de droit.
Vous avez le droit d'être contre
ce projet d'autoroute, vous avez
le droit de le dire et de
manifester, mais ne vous en
déplaise aussi, des élus ont
défendu de longue date ce projet,
de toutes sensibilités politiques,
et même de sensibilités politiques
différentes du gouvernement.
C'est ça, la démocratie et l'Etat
de droit.
Il y a eu des recours, plus d'une
dizaine devant la justice de ce
pays.
Tous ont été rejetés.
C'est cela, la démocratie et
l'Etat de droit.
Tous les responsables politiques,
quelle que soit leur opinion,
devraient rappeler ces principes
fondamentaux.
Il y a eu des référés encore cet
été.
Le juge les a tous rejetés.
Tous les recours suspensifs sont
épuisés.
Si on change les règles, plus
aucune décision démocratique
n'arrivera dans notre pays.
Je sais que vous êtes parfois un
peu plus nuancée et qu'on doit
être attachés à la vérité.
Vous ne pouvez pas dire n'importe
quoi sur le contenu de ce projet.
Il y a des arbres qui seront
défrichés et coupés, mais cinq
fois plus seront réimplantés.
Vous m'avez remis en main propre
une alternative à ce projet, que
j'ai examinée.
Il y aurait dans votre alternative
sept fois plus d'arbres coupés.
Je le dis avec gravité et
solennité dans cet hémicycle.
On ne pousse pas une personne au
martyr.
J'en veux énormément à ceux qui
ont poussé Thomas Brail à l'excès.
Il était de notre responsabilité,
je l'assume, d'avoir une
intervention de protection pour
protéger la santé et la vie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Hubert
Ott pour le groupe démocrate.
- Hubert Ott: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre des Solidarités et des
Familles.
Madame la ministre, il est des
dates que l'on ne peut oublier.
C'est le cas du mercredi 9 août
2023 et du violent incendie qui
s'est déclaré dans un gîte
accueillant des personnes en
situation de handicap mental
originaires notamment de Nancy et
de Lorraine.
Malgré la mobilisation maximale
sans faille de nos pompiers, des
forces de l'ordre et des services
de l'Etat, 10 personnes venues
passer des vacances adaptées,
ainsi qu'un de leurs
accompagnateurs, un jeune homme de
33 ans, ont tragiquement perdu la
vie.
Aujourd'hui encore, nous avons
tous ici une pensée particulière
pour leur famille.
Cet incendie meurtrier a frappé
durement l'Alsace et la Lorraine.
Il a bouleversé la France entière.
La mobilisation du gouvernement
sur place a été immédiate.
Madame la Première ministre était
présente.
Votre présence et celle de la
ministre déléguée chargée des
personnes handicapées aux côtés
des associations lorraines
concernées était importante.
Ce drame est double.
Au-delà de la tragédie que
représente ce très lourd bilan en
perte de vies humaines, il est
d'autant plus insupportable qu'il
touche le monde du handicap, celui
des associations, des structures
sociales et médico-sociales et des
aidants.
Celles et ceux qui, au quotidien,
accompagnent les personnes en
situation de handicap afin de leur
permettre de jouir des mêmes
droits que l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens.
Comme vous vous y étiez engagée,
vous avez publié, madame la
ministre, les conclusions d'un
rapport d'enquête que vous aviez
demandé sur les circonstances du
drame.
Au regard de ce rapport et de la
succession des défaillances dont
il fait état, quelles mesures
allez-vous prendre pour éviter
qu'une telle tragédie ne se
reproduise?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, mon cher collègue.
Je vous demande vraiment de tâcher
de respecter les deux minutes.
La parole est à madame la ministre
des Solidarités et des Familles.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Monsieur le député, vous l'avez
dit, il y a des dates qui,
malheureusement, marquent par la
tragédie qu'elles ont emportée.
Ce sont 10 personnes en situation
de handicap et un accompagnant qui
sont décédés dans des conditions
absolument tragiques dans
l'incendie d'un gîte.
Je veux ici rendre hommage à
l'engagement sans faille des
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont tout fait
pour tenter d'arrêter ce drame.
Immédiatement, avec la Première
ministre, le jour même, sur place,
le lendemain, avec la ministre
déléguée aux personnes
handicapées, auprès des
associations et des familles, nous
nous sommes rendues sur place et
nous avons immédiatement
diligenter une enquête.
C'était la moindre des choses
vis-à-vis des familles.
Cette inspection montre des
défaillances généralisées sur la
question dite des vacances
adaptées.
Ce sont les vacances de personnes
en situation de handicap et les
vacances des aidants qui étaient
avec.
Nous enverrons une instruction à
l'ensemble des prestataires des
vacances adaptées afin qu'ils
puissent agir.
Nous ferons en sorte que les
agréments délivrés valident les
conditions de sécurité, notamment
sur les questions de sécurité
incendie, ce qui n'avait pas été
le cas pour ce gîte et pour
l'organisme concerné.
Nous devons aller plus loin pour
diffuser une véritable culture du
contrôle.
Nous devons aux personnes
handicapées la capacité de partir
en vacances.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
Juste avant de donner la parole au
président Olivier Marleix, je veux
saluer un membre du XV
parlementaire.
Je pense qu'on peut le saluer.
S'il y a d'autres sportifs dans
l'hémicycle, qu'il se signale.
pour que je puisse les saluer
également.
Vous avez la parole, Olivier
Marleix.
- Olivier Marleix: On est très
fier de notre champion.
Est-il possible de ne jamais
apprendre de ses erreurs?
Après Alstom, nous voilà à la
veille d'un nouvel abandon de
souveraineté industrielle avec un
démembrement projeté d'un géant
des services numériques, qui
emploie 50 personnes dans notre
pays.
Les liquidateurs de l'industrie
française sont à la manoeuvre.
Ils se partagent déjà quelques
centaines de millions d'euros de
commissions et d'honoraires, ce
qui est pas mal pour une
entreprise qui est soi-disant au
pied du mur.
On nous racontera que cette
entreprise est privée et qu'il
faut laisser faire.
Ce serait oublier que l'entreprise
n'est pas une création spontanée
du marché.
Elle est la volonté du général de
Gaulle de doter la France de
supercalculateurs.
Elle est l'héritière de Bull et a
bénéficié de centaines de millions
d'euros de commandes publiques
ainsi que de recherche publique
par le ministère des Armées.
Cette entreprise est là la seule
en Europe capable de fabriquer des
supercalculateurs indispensables
dans le monde de l'intelligence
artificielle.
Elle héberge aussi les données
sensibles de nombreux ministères.
Au coeur de votre stratégie France
2030, sur le futur ordinateur
quantique.
Cette entreprise a perdu la
confiance des marchés, mais elle
est rentable.
Rien ne justifie la précipitation.
Votre gouvernement est-il donc
prêt à intervenir pour sauvegarder
cet acteur majeur de notre
souveraineté industrielle?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix, vous
avez souligné avec force
l'importance du dossier Atos.
Cette conviction, je la partage
totalement.
C'est un enjeu de souveraineté
essentiel pour notre pays.
C'est pour ça que nous suivons ce
sujet avec la plus grande
attention.
Nous sommes très attentifs à ce
que les activités sensibles,
rassemblées dans l'entité Atos,
dispose des moyens nécessaires
pour poursuivre son développement.
Je pense à l'activité des
supercalculateurs, en particulier.
L'opération de rachat en cours
concerne la branche Atos
spécialisée dans l'auto-gérance.
Même si l'opération a été menée à
son terme, elle n'aurait aucune
incidence en termes de contrôle ou
de droits de blocage sur les
activités sensibles.
Pour de telles activités, je
rappelle que, si une entité
étrangère veut monter au capital
d'une entreprise française, cela
nécessite une autorisation du
ministère de l'Economie.
A cet égard, notre pays est mieux
armé pour défendre sa
souveraineté.
Depuis six ans, nous avons
considérablement renforcé des
dispositifs de contrôle des
investissements étrangers en
France.
Nous avons abaissé le seuil des
contrôles et nous avons étendu les
semi-conducteurs à de nouveaux
domaines de contrôle.
Le nombre de contrôles a plus que
doublé depuis 2022.
Monsieur le président Marleix,
nous défendons les intérêts
stratégiques de notre pays.
Concernant Atos, nous resterons
très vigilants à ce que nos
intérêts souverains soient
préservés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix?
- Olivier Marleix: Je suis un peu
inquiet.
J'ai le sentiment que vous avez
déjà acté la scission de
l'entreprise.
Ce n'est pas le rôle des banquiers
d'affaires d'imaginer l'avenir de
ces entreprises.
C'est le rôle de l'Etat, c'est
même un devoir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq, pour
le groupe GDR.
- Jean-Paul Lecoq: Avec les
putschs au Niger et au Gabon, cet
été, notre politique coloniale en
Afrique a connu un des plus grands
revers.
Ce même colonialisme,
qui est dans les outre-mer, ne
fait pas l'unanimité.
Au Sahel, vous avez demandé aux
militaires de faire de
l'humanitaire.
Aux humanitaires, vous avez
demandé de faire de la politique.
Aux diplomates, vous avez demandé
de n'être que la caisse de
résonance des multinationales
françaises.
Quand vous prétendez défendre la
démocratie, les peuples vous
répondent en rejetant les
tricheurs.
Les peuples africains sont
anti-politique française.
Ils veulent accéder à leur
deuxième indépendance, celle de la
souveraineté économique et
financière.
Nous devrions les écouter.
Nous devrions fermer les bases
militaires en Afrique et en finir
avec le franc CFA.
Que dire du franc Pacifique?
Au lieu de cela, vous continuez à
exiger des sanctions
internationales qui étouffent les
peuples.
Vous avez même exigé la fin de la
coopération culturelle, avec tous
les artistes maliens, burkinabés
et nigériens.
Vous avez bloqué l'obtention des
visas pour les étudiants
ressortissants de ces Etats.
En appliquant ces injustes
sanctions collectives, vous vous
en prenez au puissant vecteur de
paix que sont les coopérations
culturelles et intellectuelles.
Quand l'arrogance néo-coloniale
va-t-elle quitter nos politiques
publiques?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Catherine Colonna,
ministre de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Monsieur le
député Jean-Paul Lecoq, il
m'arrive d'être d'accord avec
vous, j'espère que personne ne
s'en offusque, mais là, je ne
saurais l'être tant vos propos
dépassent la réalité.
Au Gabon comme au Niger, notre
politique, guidée par les deux
principes qui nous gouvernent
toujours.
Premièrement, nous condamnons tous
les coups d'Etat.
Deuxièmement, nous soutenons les
organisations régionales.
Voilà la réalité.
Je voudrais vous rappeler que
l'Afrique ne se réduit pas au
Sahel et à quelques juntes qui
remettent en cause la France pour
masquer leurs propres échecs.
Ne faites pas comme eux.
La relation entre la France et la
plupart des 54 pays africains se
porte très bien.
En 15 ans, le volume de nos
investissements a doublé.
C'est un fait.
Nos universités accueillent
aujourd'hui 92.000 étudiants
africains, soit 40% de plus qu'en
2017.
C'est un fait.
Nous avons augmenté notre aide au
développement de 50% en six ans.
C'est un fait.
Partout sur le continent, nous
menons des coopérations avec les
scientifiques, les sportifs et les
artistes.
A propos des artistes,
permettez-moi de dire que les
mesures que vous évoquez n'ont
jamais été prises ni demandées.
Nous traitons l'Afrique sur un
pied d'égalité.
Nous traitons avec elle les grands
défis de demain, que sont la faim,
le développement, la santé
mondiale.
Nous soutenons le poids de
l'Afrique dans le monde entier.
Nous le faisons au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU.
L'Union Africaine vient d'entrer
au G20.
Voilà la réalité.
Voilà ce que nous faisons avec nos
partenaires africains.
- Jean-Paul Lecoq: Entendez ce que
disent les peuples africains.
Evidemment, ce n'est pas toute
l'Afrique.
Les deux minutes qui me sont
accordées ne me permettent pas de
faire la liste, et vous savez très
bien que la partie CEDEAO a un
message à donner à la France.
Ce message, vous avez du mal à
l'entendre.
C'était le sens de cette question.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Virginie Lanlo, pour le
groupe Renaissance.
Bienvenue à l'Assemblée, madame la
députée.
- Virginie Lanlo: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
Je souhaiterais vous lire le
message qu'une jeune fille a
récemment envoyé à son ancienne
camarade.
"Il y a des années de cela, j'ai
subi de ta part harcèlement,
humiliations et attouchements.
Ces agissements ont bousillé ma
vie d'enfant et d'adolescente.
J'ai pu me reconstruire et
construire une famille formidable,
mais jamais je n'oublierai ces
heures de souffrance et de
détresse.
J'ai pensé dénoncer ces
agissements, cela fait maintenant
plus de 40 ans.
C'est loin, mais cette jeune
fille, c'était moi."
Je ne crois pas avoir été la seule
à être victime de harcèlement.
Un enfant sur quatre en est
victime.
Combien en parlent?
Le harcèlement scolaire est un
drame intime.
Il tue.
Le harcèlement scolaire, c'est un
drame qui porte mal son nom car il
ne s'arrête pas aux murs de
l'école.
Il continue après les cours, au
football ou à la danse.
Il revient par messages ou sur les
réseaux sociaux.
Il hante les rêves, qui deviennent
des cauchemars.
Il a droit de cité partout.
C'est un drame qui se niche dans
l'anodin, une violence qui ne
réclame pas de coups, une blessure
qui ne se pare pas de sang.
Je voudrais vous lire ces mots
d'enfants.
"Le harcèlement, c'est comme
l'uranium, ça brûle de
l'intérieur.
Le harcèlement, ça commence par
une étincelle, ça finit par un
incendie.
Maman, ce n'est pas pour rien que
j'ai voulu mourir."
Je voudrais dire les mots de tous
ceux qui se sont donné la mort
avant de parler.
Le silence les a emportés.
Il n'est rien de pire que de ne
pas parler, sauf peut-être de ne
pas parler et de ne pas être
entendu.
En parlant de honte, vous avez mis
les mots justes sur la réaction de
l'académie.
Pouvez-vous nous dire quels actes
vous comptez mettre en place?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gabriel Attal, ministre
de l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Madame la députée Virginie Lanlo,
Marion, 13 ans, Dina, 14 ans,
Ambre, 11 ans, Lucas, 13 ans,
Thibault, 10 ans, Chanel, 10 ans,
Marie, 15 ans, Lindsay, 13 ans,
Nicolas, 15 ans.
Le harcèlement scolaire ne connaît
pas de frontières.
Ces jeunes ne demandent qu'à
s'aimer et à aimer les autres.
Et ma nomination au ministère de
l'Education nationale fait de la
lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire ma priorité absolue.
Je ne reculerai devant rien!
Je ne reculerai devant rien pour
mieux prévenir!
que la peur change de camp!
Je ne reculerai devant rien pour
que la honte change de camp!
Nous avons d'ores et déjà
commencer à agir avec les
décisions importantes qui ont été
prises, dès cet été.
Demain, la Première ministre
présentera le plan
interministériel de lutte contre
le harcèlement pour aller plus
loin, pour mieux détecter, pour
mieux réagir.
Il s'est engagé sur ce sujet.
Nous avons appelé à un électrochoc
et je constate que l'électrochoc a
commencé.
Nous devons être plus efficaces
dans la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire.
C'est ce que nous devons à tous
les élèves et c'est ce que nous
devons à toutes les familles de
France!
C'est ce que nous devons à notre
nation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Benjamin
Lucas, pour le groupe écologiste.
- Benjamin Lucas: Ce mardi, le
président de la République s'est
entretenu à Rome avec la
présidente du Conseil italien, la
néofasciste Giorgia Meloni.
Ils se reverront à Malte.
La France tiendra-t-elle son rang
et se montrera-t-elle fidèle à sa
tradition d'accueil, à son message
humaniste?
Le président Macron cessera-t-il
de mentir en disant que l'Europe
est le continent qui fait le plus,
alors que l'écrasante majorité des
migrations dans le monde se fait
entre les pays du sud?
Comprendra-t-il que les 40.000 km
de
murs construits lors du 21e siècle
ne produisent que deux effets?
L'enrichissement des passeurs et
l'augmentation du nombre de
cadavres dans la Méditerranée.
Comprendrez-vous que nous ne
connaissons pas de crise
migratoire, de submersion et
d'invasion, comme le prétend
l'extrême droite, mais que 30 ans
de politique répressive ont créé
une crise de fraternité, à
laquelle doit répondre une
politique ambitieuse de la prison?
Elle doit garantir le droit à la
scolarisation pour les mineurs non
accompagnés.
Elle doit soutenir les
humanitaires, qui sauvent des vies
de Calais à Marseille.
Je veux leur rendre hommage, ici.
Entendrez-vous ce que vous disent
tous les chercheurs, toutes les
études, tous les chiffres?
Votre prétendu appel d'air
n'existe pas.
Il n'est pas dû à notre modèle
social, que vous vous acharnez à
effriter.
Choisirez-vous la vérité et la
confiance plutôt que le mensonge
et la peur?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie pour cela.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député Benjamin Lucas,
les questions migratoires sont des
questions difficiles parce
qu'elles touchent l'humain.
Ce sont des humains qui traversent
parfois des conditions extrêmement
difficiles, pour aller vers la
terre qu'ils pensent être promise,
en tout cas une terre qui puisse
leur apporter une protection.
Il est évident que la France a
toujours tenu son rang.
500.000 personnes sont protégées
par notre pays sur le sol
national.
Nous avons entre 100.000 et
130.000 demandes d'asile chaque
année.
Nous essayons de les étudier de la
meilleure manière possible devant
les difficultés croissantes.
C'est pour cela que, depuis 2017,
nous finançons 123.000 places de
demandeurs d'asile.
80% des gens qui demandent l'asile
sont logés par l'Etat et par les
impôts des Français.
Tenir son rang et donner l'asile,
ce n'est pas tout accepter.
Il faut distinguer...
Il n'y a pas une démocratie au
monde, même les Verts allemands,
qui ont voté le pacte migratoire.
Vous devriez être solidaire de vos
collègues.
Il faut distinguer la personne qui
vient demander l'asile dans notre
continent et qui doit être
accueillie le plus rapidement
possible.
C'est ce que nous avons fait
figurer dans le texte que j'aurai
l'honneur de présenter dans les
semaines qui viennent.
Nous ne pouvons pas accepter toute
immigration illégale qui n'est pas
passée dans les cadres légaux.
Nous devons aussi accepter qu'on
ne peut pas, sans critères,
prendre toutes les personnes sur
le sol européen, par défaut de
capacité d'intégration.
Dans votre proposition, il y a une
partie de la réponse.
La France prendra sa part, mais
elle ne peut pas prendre la part
de tous les autres.
- Benjamin Lucas: La France est
grande quand elle porte un message
de fraternité et d'accueil.
Décidément, le macronisme restera
comme quelque chose de tout petit.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Estelle Youssoupha, pour
le groupe LIOT.
- Estelle Youssoupha: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre, parce que c'est ici
l'action de son gouvernement que
je questionne.
Demain matin, Mayotte sera dans la
rue, pour hurler de soif, pour
vous rappeler que nous survivons
sans eau.
Je veux vous rappeler que l'accès
à l'eau potable est en droit que
vous devez nous garantir.
Nous n'avons que quelques heures
d'eau tous les deux ou trois
jours.
C'est une eau qu'il faut faire
bouillir avant de consommer.
Une eau puante, marron, mais
"potable".
Le pack d'eau se vend entre 5 et
12 euros à Mayotte.
Pour une famille de quatre
personnes, c'est au minimum six
bouteilles par jour.
Un budget de 300 euros par mois.
Alors que votre gouvernement
distribue des chèques carburant,
quand allez-vous mettre en place
un chèque eau pour Mayotte?
Quand allez-vous effacer les
factures d'eau pour nos
concitoyens de Mayotte?
Le gouvernement a distribué
600.000 bouteilles d'eau pour les
plus vulnérables.
Merci, mais quid du reste de la
population?
Parlons du risque de typhoïde et
du choléra sur notre île, qui
compte de nombreux bidonvilles.
La crise sanitaire est imminente,
alors que notre hôpital s'effondre
avec des centaines de soignants
qui manquent à l'appel dans le
plus grand désert médical de
France.
Certains hôpitaux ferment, faute
d'eau.
Quid de la scolarité de nos
enfants?
Pourquoi ne profitez-vous pas de
la sécheresse pour nettoyer la
rivière?
Pourquoi n'avez-vous pas commandé
des citernes pour équiper tous les
foyers?
Combien de temps Mayotte peut-elle
tenir en raison des coupures et
des réserves d'eau?
Mayotte est en train de basculer
en enfer.
Le préfet est dépassé.
Votre gouvernement a-t-il
démissionné à Mayotte?
Sommes-nous sortis de la
République?
Quand allez-vous agir?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie et la parole est à
monsieur Philippe Vigier, ministre
délégué aux outre-mer.
- Philippe Vigier: Madame la
députée, la situation de Mayotte
est inédite et gravissime.
Avec le gouvernement, je peux vous
dire que nous sommes totalement
mobilisés autour de la Première
ministre et de Gérald Darmanin.
Cette crise, madame la députée,
exige d'être à la hauteur des
enjeux.
Tout d'abord, le préfet a dû
prendre des mesures drastiques de
réduction de l'eau tous les deux
jours sur trois.
Les Mahorais ont de l'eau un jour
sur trois.
Nous avons mis en place des
chemins de l'eau pour sécuriser
les écoles et les établissements
de santé.
Nous avons mis en place dans
chacune des communes, en accord
avec les élus, ce qu'on appelle
des "rampes d'eau", pour apporter
de l'eau là où il n'y en a pas.
Nous avons apporté à certaines
écoles des bonbonnes de 1000
litres.
Ca ne suffit pas.
Vous l'avez rappelé.
Je tiens à dire devant la
représentation nationale que grâce
à vous, nous avons élargi le
public qui bénéficie de bouteilles
d'eau.
C'est 1,4 million de bouteilles
d'eau qui ont été commandées.
Les Mahorais que nous souhaitons
le plus protéger auront des
bouteilles d'eau pendant cette
période de crise.
300 millions d'euros sont engagés
immédiatement pour faire un chemin
d'eau potable.
Il y a énormément de fuites, dans
les réseaux mahorais.
La légion est mobilisée.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur a
mobilisé la Sécurité civile.
Les armées sont mobilisées avec un
service militaire adapté.
Les élus le sont, avec le centre
de communion sociale.
Deux usines de dessalement verront
le jour à la fin de 2024.
En attendant, tout le gouvernement
sera mobilisé.
Sous l'autorité de la Première
ministre, croyez bien que nous
serons à vos côtés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Maud
Bregeon pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Maud Bregeon: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Solidarités et des Familles.
La précarité qui touche de
nombreuses familles françaises est
rarement un hasard social.
Au contraire, elle se transmet
d'une génération à l'autre.
Certains appelleront ça
"assignation à résidence".
D'autres, "déterminisme".
Le constat est le même.
Notre enjeu est double.
Il faut aider les Français touchés
par la pauvreté à en sortir
rapidement.
Il faut lutter contre cette
reproduction qui touche toutes les
sphères de la vie.
Si notre modèle social fait partie
des plus robustes et des plus
redistributifs au monde, la
réalité que j'ai décrite
précédemment est accrue par les
crises que l'on traverse,
notamment par la crise climatique.
Si la planète est la même pour
tous, nous ne sommes pas tous
égaux face au réchauffement
climatique.
Les classes populaires en seront
les premières victimes.
Elles sont les plus vulnérables.
Face à notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles, quand les prix
des factures d'électricité
grimpent, quand l'accès à l'emploi
devient plus difficile, quand on
n'a plus les moyens de sortir de
sa passoire thermique...
La question écologique appelle une
réponse sociale et solidaire.
Loin des discours moralisateurs et
inaudibles, pouvez-vous nous dire
concrètement quel accent vous
comptez mener pour permettre aux
familles les plus modestes d'y
faire face, dans le cadre du plan
solidarité que vous portez au sein
du gouvernement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Aurore Bergé, ministre
des Solidarités et des Familles.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci, madame la
députée.
Je sais l'engagement qui est le
vôtre sur les enjeux de transition
écologique et énergétique.
La pauvreté se transmet dans notre
pays de génération en génération.
On estime qu'on met en moyenne
sept générations à sortir de la
pauvreté durablement.
Cela signifie que, quand on est
pauvre, on peut rester pauvre dans
notre pays.
C'est bien cela qu'il faut
impérativement briser.
Il faut le briser avec des enjeux
structurels.
Dans notre génération, on pensait
pouvoir accès au plein emploi et
lutter définitivement contre le
chômage de masse.
C'est aujourd'hui possible et nous
allons y arriver.
Il faut aller plus loin pour faire
que le travail paye.
C'est tout l'enjeu de la
conférence sociale, portée par le
ministre du Travail.
Il y a la manière avec laquelle
la transition énergétique.
Aujourd'hui, on a une sorte de
double peine qui touche les
personnes qui sont les plus
vulnérables dans notre pays.
Ils sont moins responsables du
dérèglement climatique,
mais ils ne payent plus.
Lutter contre la pauvreté, c'est
aussi garantir que la transition
écologique et énergétique soit
juste.
Pour qu'elle soit juste, elle doit
être solidaire.
C'est ce que nous faisons avec le
ministre de l'Ecologie, notamment
sur la précarité énergétique.
Nous doublons les moyens pour
lutter contre cette précarité
énergétique.
C'est ce que nous faisons sur la
question du logement.
Il y a 203.000 logements
d'urgence.
C'est ce que nous faisons sur
l'alimentation.
Il y a les petits-déjeuners
gratuits.
Ce sont les garanties que nos
enfants ont accès à une
alimentation saine et de qualité.
Notre engagement est total dans la
lutte contre la pauvreté dans
notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Kévin
Pfeffer, du Rassemblement
National.
- Kévin Pfeffer: Monsieur le
ministre des Comptes publics,
quand vous avez votre taxe
foncière qui augmente, ce n'est
pas le gouvernement, c'est votre
commune qui le décide.
C'est un scandale.
C'est d'un culot monstre, ces mots
du président Macron.
Un culot monstre au service du
mensonge.
La hausse de la taxe foncière est
bel et bien due au gouvernement.
Cette hausse de 7,1%, du jamais-vu
depuis près de 40 ans,
c'est dû au gouvernement.
Grenoble: +24%.
Mais cela n'arrive pas dans les
communes gérée par le RN.
Nous avons proposé un amendement
lors du dernier budget.
Un amendement pour plafonner à 2%
les valeurs locatives, notamment.
Vous les avez rejetés.
Vous avez imposé vos choix par
49.3.
Nous faisons le choix de la paix
fiscale et de rendre l'argent au
contribuable.
Quand allez-vous cesser de
mépriser les élus locaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Thomas Cazenave.
- Thomas Cazenave: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, je veux le
dire clairement: la taxe foncière
est une taxe 100% locale.
L'Assemblée nationale, en 2016, a
choisi à l'immense majorité
l'indexation des bases foncières
sur l'inflation.
Ce n'est pas une décision de ce
gouvernement.
C'est un choix d'indexer les bases
foncières.
Sur cette base-là, les élus, en
responsabilité, choisissent
d'augmenter les taux, de maintenir
les taux ou de baisser les taux.
Ils ont le choix.
C'est un impôt local.
En aucune manière, c'est
l'occasion de vous dire que vous
ne pouvez pas expliquer la hausse
de la taxe foncière par la
suppression de la taxe
d'habitation qui a été compensée à
l'euro près par l'Etat, pour les
communes.
Je tiens à vous dire, monsieur le
député, que quand vous défendez un
amendement qui vise à plafonner
l'évolution des bases foncière à
2%, vous privez les collectivités
territoriales de 1,9 milliard
d'euros.
C'est deux fois l'indexation de la
DGF que vous réclamez.
Un peu de cohérence, monsieur le
député.
Vous avez l'indexation à géométrie
variable.
Un jour vous indexez la dotation,
le lendemain, vous voulez la taxe
foncière.
Je dois dire qu'il faut cesser
d'opposer l'Etat et les
collectivités territoriales.
Notre méthode, c'est le dialogue
et la concertation.
Ne vous en déplaise, monsieur le
député.
C'est la seule méthode qui marche.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Paul
Vannier, pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Paul Vannier: Merci, madame la
présidente.
"Abaya pas de profs", voilà la
triste réalité de cette rentrée.
3000 postes vacants à l'issue des
concours d'enseignants.
1500 postes supprimés au budget de
l'an passé.
Au moins un professeur manquant
dans 50% de nos collèges et de nos
lycées.
Cette situation a une explication:
la crise de recrutement.
Elle vient principalement de la
politique d'appauvrissement mise
en oeuvre par votre gouvernement.
Depuis 2017, les professeurs de
notre pays ont perdu près de 12%
de leur pouvoir d'achat.
C'est l'équivalent d'un mois de
salaire en moins chaque année.
Il y a 40 ans, un enseignant en
début de carrière gagnait
l'équivalent de deux SMIC.
Aujourd'hui, il débute à 1,2 SMIC.
Quelle autre profession a connu
pareil déclassement?
Mercredi dernier, ces vérités
étaient exposées par les
organisations syndicales reçues en
audition par la Commission de
l'éducation.
Les représentants enseignants ont
reçu une bordée d'injures venant
du mépris des macronistes.
Monsieur le ministre, vous avez
fait connaître votre intention de
comprendre le fonctionnement de
l'école publique.
Vous vous préparez à un séjour de
découverte.
Ce rendez-vous en terre inconnue
vous livrera un enseignement:
l'école publique, comme l'hôpital
public, est en voie
d'effondrement.
Il faut la reconstruire en
commençant par reconnaître
l'expertise des enseignants et la
valeur sociale de leur métier.
Assez de job dating, monsieur le
ministre.
Allez-vous augmenter massivement
tous les enseignants afin de
garantir le droit à l'éducation de
tous nos enfants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gabriel
Attal, ministre de l'Education
nationale et de la Jeunesse.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député Paul Vannier,
j'étais ce matin pendant trois
heures avec les organisations
syndicales à l'occasion du Comité
social d'action ministérielle.
On a notamment parlé de la
question de l'attractivité du
métier d'enseignant et des
rémunérations.
Il y a des débats sur l'ampleur
des revalorisations qui ont eu
lieu en cette rentrée, mais tous
ont reconnu qu'il s'agissait de la
plus forte revalorisation depuis
20 ou 30 ans dans notre pays.
La réalité, c'est qu'il y a trois
ans, un enseignant en début de
carrière néotitulaire gagnait 1700
euros net par mois.
En cette rentrée, il gagne 2100
Ca fait 400 euros de plus en trois
ans.
Vous avez abordé la comparaison
avec le SMIC.
En l'an 2000, un enseignant en
début de carrière gagnait 1,7
SMIC.
C'était tombé à 1,5 SMIC en 2013.
En janvier prochain, ce sera 1,8
SMIC.
Nous avons effacé l'effondrement.
Il faut continuer à aller plus
loin.
La concerne tous les enseignants.
Chaque enseignant gagne entre 125
et 130 euros net de plus qu'à la
rentrée 2022.
Il faut continuer à avancer sur
l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant.
Ca ne se résume pas à l'activité
salariale.
Il faut parler des mobilités et
des conditions d'exercice.
J'ai ouvert un travail spécifique
avec les organisations syndicales.
On s'est réunis sur le sujet.
Un programme de travail a été
défini.
J'avance avec les organisations
syndicales sur ce sujet.
Oui, on doit agir pour renforcer
l'attractivité du métier
d'enseignant.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Lise
Magnier pour le groupe Horizons.
- Lise Magnier: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre des Transports.
Ma question concerne les camions
de 48 tonnes pour le transport de
la betterave sucrière.
A ce titre, elle concerne tout
autant l'agriculture, l'industrie
et les collectivités ainsi que la
transition écologique.
La filière de la betterave
sucrière est l'une de nos filières
agricoles majeures par son poids
économique, sa participation, sa
souveraineté et par les emplois
qu'elle offre sur les territoires
ruraux.
Cette filière a souhaité répondre
à la triple problématique posée
par l'organisation du transport
dès 2019
pendant la campagne betteravière.
Depuis deux ans, il y a une
expérimentation du transport par
48 tonnes.
Le bilan est positif: une
réduction des poids lourds sur les
routes d'au moins 10% avec des
gains de productivité associés,
une réduction claire de
l'empreinte carbone et de réels
avantages en termes de sécurité
routière.
Aucune critique n'a été formulée
sur les résultats de cette
expérimentation, dont la
méthodologie et la transparence
sont reconnues par l'ensemble des
parties prenantes.
Pourtant, ni la généralisation, ni
la poursuite de cette
expérimentation ne sont possibles
pour la prochaine campagne
betteravière qui s'ouvre dans
quelques semaines faute de
décision prise à temps par le
comité interministériel.
Comment peut-on expliquer à
l'ensemble des acteurs que leurs
efforts ne pourront être
poursuivis cette année?
Surtout, quelle orientation
allez-vous donner lors du prochain
comité interministériel pour
poursuivre la poursuite de ce
transport en 48 tonnes unanimement
approuvé et demandé par les
professionnels locaux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Clément
Beaune, ministre chargé des
Transports.
- Clément Beaune: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
madame la députée Magnier, merci
de souligner ce sujet extrêmement
important pour votre département
de la Marne, comme pour beaucoup
de territoires pour lesquels
l'économie sucrière et
betteravière est essentielle.
Je travaille étroitement avec le
ministre de l'Agriculture.
C'est une attente très forte.
Nous avons depuis quelques
semaines les résultats.
Le bilan est globalement positif.
Je me dois d'être un peu plus
nuancé que le panorama que vous
avez tracé.
Un certain nombre d'acteurs
professionnels, notamment dans le
secteur des transports, sont plus
nuancés que les professionnels de
l'agriculture et de la filière sur
ce transport.
Des petites difficultés ont été
remontées.
L'impact sur les chaussées,
l'entretien des routes, notamment
pour les plus petites communes,
sont importants.
Je suis prêt à vous proposer deux
choses extrêmement rapidement.
D'abord, pour la campagne qui va
s'ouvrir, si nous pouvons
prolonger les choses pour donner
cette respiration attendue à la
filière, et deuxièmement, pour la
suite, nous devons regarder le
rapport plus en détails et
consulter les départements de
France, l'association des maires
de France dans les prochaines
semaines pour recueillir leur
avis.
Début 2024, il faudra savoir si
nous irons vers une reconduite,
car nous devons le faire
objectivement.
Prenons quelques jours pour
prendre une décision rapide pour
la campagne qui s'ouvre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Jocelyn
Dessigny pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Jocelyn Dessigny: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Santé.
Monsieur le ministre, le cancer
est de loin considéré comme la
maladie du siècle.
Chaque année en France, 2500
enfants sont touchés par un cancer
pédiatrique.
Chaque année en France, 500
enfants meurent d'un cancer
pédiatrique.
La raison est simple: les
traitements pour adultes ne sont
pas adaptés aux enfants.
Nos médecins ont besoin de la
recherche pour les soigner.
La recherche médicale, c'est le
parent pauvre, bien loin des
préoccupations de l'Etat qui
n'investit que 2,2% de son PIB.
La stratégie nationale de santé
2023-2033 montre ses limites, à
l'heure où nos voisins allemands
ont doublé leur budget pour
consacrer 128 milliards d'euros à
cette recherche.
Les Etats-Unis y consacrent 792
milliards d'euros.
Ces pays ont des résultats,
trouvent des traitements, mais ces
derniers ne sont pas accessibles
aux enfants de France.
Ce n'est pour autant pas une
fatalité.
Notre pays a la possibilité de
réduire le nombre de décès de nos
enfants de manière significative.
Pour cela, il est de notre devoir
de mobiliser, d'encourager,
d'accompagner nos chercheurs en
leur donnant les moyens
nécessaires pour faire leur
travail.
Ces hommes ont des compétences
précieuses pour notre santé et il
faut leur donner les moyens
suffisants pour qu'ils restent en
France.
Monsieur le ministre, quel signal
avez-vous à leur adresser
aujourd'hui?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Aurélien
Rousseau, ministre de la Santé et
de la Prévention.
- Aurélien Rousseau: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, permettez-moi
tout d'abord de saluer
l'initiative Septembre en Or qui
est relayée dans cet hémicycle.
Elle vous a réunis aujourd'hui et
nous réunit tous autour de cette
grande cause que sont les cancers
pédiatriques.
Ce sont des souffrances
intolérables, des souffrances pour
les parents, pour les enfants.
Ce sont aussi des solidarités
inoubliables.
Je pense ici aux soignants qui, de
l'institut Gustave Roussy en
passant par les hôpitaux de Lyon,
recherchent et soignent, trouvent
des solutions.
80% des cancers diagnostiqués
trouvent une solution.
Monsieur le député, vous l'avez
dit, 20% de ces cancers sont des
maladies que l'on n'arrive pas à
soigner.
Je présiderai dans quelques jours
le Comité de pilotage de la
stratégie décennale sur le cancer.
Je peux vous l'annoncer ici, la
priorité des priorités, c'est
celle de l'investissement dans la
recherche pour ces cancers
pédiatriques parce
qu'effectivement, les protocoles
de recherche sont plus longs et
plus difficiles.
L'optimisation thérapeutique est
aussi un point important.
L'accompagnement des familles un
un point décisif.
En effet, nous devons avoir une
mobilisation collective qui fait
que la France doit rester très
haut dans l'accès aux médicaments
innovants.
Aujourd'hui, on a accès aux
médicaments les plus innovants
pour soigner les cancers
pédiatriques en France.
Les soignants le savent.
Je finis en soulignant l'intérêt
d'aider les parents, d'accompagner
les parents.
Je salue pour ça les lois portées
par votre collègue, Paul
Christophe.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
Monsieur Dessigny?
- Jocelyn Dessigny: Maëlys est
atteinte d'un cancer des os.
Elle aurait aimé être ici pour
entendre votre réponse, mais elle
est clouée sur un lit d'hôpital.
Elle se bat pour trouver des fonds
pour la recherche.
Monsieur le ministre, elle attend
de vous une réponse claire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bastien
Lachaud pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Bastien Lachaud: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la Première ministre, 19
bombardements et plusieurs
centaines de victimes civiles en
Egypte exécutées par le régime
d'Al-Sissi.
Voilà le bilan de l'opération
française menée, très loin des
objectifs de lutte contre le
terrorisme invoqués à l'origine.
Du renseignement militaire le
prouve.
Le classement secret-défense des
notes est illégitime.
Il vise à faire obstacle à la
manifestation de la vérité.
Il est contraire à l'instruction
générale de le faire.
Qu'avez-vous fait?
Vous avez porté plainte contre un
média et une journaliste qui ont
révélé ce scandale.
Les conséquences?
40 heures de garde à vue pour la
journaliste et une perquisition
dans le seul but de débusquer les
sources.
Ce sont les principes fondateurs
de notre République.
Vous bafouez notre démocratie.
Madame la Première ministre, il
est urgent que cesse cette dérive
autoritaire.
Madame la Première ministre,
allez-vous retirer la plainte du
ministère des Armées?
Allez-vous garantir le secret des
sources des journalistes?
Allez-vous cesser la persécution
d'Ariane Lavrilleux?
Allez-vous cesser de vendre des
armes qui servent quotidiennement
à réprimer le peuple égyptien?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti, ministre de la
Justice et garde des Sceaux.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, ne vous en
déplaise, la justice de notre pays
est totalement indépendante.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
- Bastien Lachaud: Monsieur le
ministre, ce n'est pas une
réponse.
Je ne vous ai pas interrogé sur
l'action de la justice.
Je vous ai interrogé sur la
plainte que le gouvernement a
déposée, sur le choix que le
gouvernement a fait de classer
secret-défense les notes de la
direction militaire.
La culpabilité de la France a été
cachée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
Monsieur le ministre de la
Justice?
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Ne vous en
déplaise, monsieur le député,
lorsque l'action publique est en
marche, la justice doit faire son
travail et si la justice estime
que cette plainte ne doit pas
prospérer, elle le dira.
Si elle estime le contraire, elle
le dira en toute indépendance, une
fois encore.
Une fois encore, c'est ma réponse,
ne vous en déplaise.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, monsieur le ministre.
La parole...
Vous êtes libre de vos questions,
le gouvernement est libre de ses
réponses.
La parole est à monsieur Ludovic
Mendes pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Ludovic Mendes: Merci, madame la
présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à la
ministre des Sports.
Ce vendredi 6 septembre a été
marqué par la victoire
de la France.
Je suis avec beaucoup d'attention
et d'émotion cette Coupe du Monde.
D'autres Coupes du monde ont eu
lieu juste avant celle-ci.
Elle nous a permis de voir
l'équipe de France triompher et
être sacrée championne du monde.
Nous sommes invaincus, avec quatre
victoires en quatre matchs.
Merci pour les honneurs du début
de séance, madame la présidente.
C'est un sans-faute pour le rugby.
Nous espérons que les Bleus du XV
de France continuent sur cette
dynamique.
Permettez-moi de féliciter
l'ensemble des bénévoles et des
clubs qui font vivre cette Coupe
du Monde sur l'ensemble du
territoire, comme cela se fait à
Metz.
Cet amour du sport m'oblige à
paraphraser l'entraîneur du XV
parlementaire.
"Que nous jouions un match du
championnat ou une Coupe du Monde,
les émotions et les frissons que
nous procurent ce sport sont les
mêmes."
Nous sommes à la mi-temps de cette
Coupe du Monde.
Nous pouvons lire dans les médias
que nous explosons les compteurs.
Qu'en est-il vraiment?
Qu'en est-il du bilan à
mi-parcours?
Madame la ministre, conjointement
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur,
Gérald Darmanin, vous êtes
régulièrement sur le terrain pour
vous assurer de la bonne
organisation des matchs.
La Coupe du Monde de rugby est un
challenge d'organisation, comme le
seront prochainement les Jeux
Olympiques et Paralympiques.
Pouvons-nous avoir confiance dans
notre capacité à rayonner?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Amélie
Oudéa-Castéra.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Monsieur
le député, "je n'ai jamais vu
une ambiance pareille.
C'était dingue, c'était insensé",
ce sont les mots
de Jonathan Sexton,
le capitaine
de l'équipe d'Irlande.
Cette Coupe du Monde est
particulièrement bien organisée.
Passé le temps de rodage, nous
sommes au rendez-vous grâce à
l'action de Gérald Darmanin.
Nous sommes au rendez-vous de la
sécurité.
fluidité dans les transports dans
le respect du dialogue social.
Grâce à un travail d'équipe autour
du comité d'organisation France
2023, avec les préfets et les
volontaires, nous sommes au
rendez-vous
d'une Coupe du Monde optimisée à
laquelle je veille
personnellement, site par site.
Je continuerai de veiller à cela
rencontre après rencontre.
J'ajoute que cette Coupe du Monde
porte des engagements forts sur le
plan écologique et social.
Le roi Charles III, lors de sa
visite récente, disait que nous
méritions tous ses remerciements
pour ce tournoi exceptionnel que
l'on accueille avec tant de
panache.
Ce sont des mots qui honorent
notre pays.
Ils renforcent notre confiance
pour la suite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, madame
la ministre.
Je suis désolée.
La parole est à madame Isabelle
Santiago pour le groupe
socialiste.
- Isabelle Santiago: Ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères.
Nous sommes nombreux à condamner
avec force l'injustifiable
agression militaire dont s'est à
nouveau rendue coupable
l'Azerbaïdjan envers la population
arménienne du Haut-Karabakh.
C'est la poursuite du processus
d'extermination des Arméniens
engagé par le régime criminel de
Bakou.
Il s'agit d'une épuration
ethnique.
Ce crime d'agression de
l'Azerbaïdjan survient après qu'il
a interdit tout approvisionnement
en nourriture et en énergie depuis
le 12 décembre dernier.
120.000 Arméniens, dont 30.000
enfants, risquent à chaque instant
leur vie.
Indignons-nous.
Déjà des vies ont été perdues.
Voir l'exode du peuple arménien
sur les routes du Haut-Karabakh
est un crève-coeur.
Nous pleurons depuis ce week-end
avec la diaspora arménienne de
voir ces images.
La France a un lien historique et
fraternel avec l'Arménie.
Il est de notre devoir d'agir.
Madame la ministre, la France a
fait un communiqué clair sur la
question.
Désormais, il faut des actes.
La France doit demander l'adoption
sans délai d'une résolution du
conseil de l'ONU.
Elle doit demander une force
internationale, elle doit saisir
la Cour pénale internationale et
prendre des poursuites contre le
président Aliev.
Nous attendons que Paris apporte
un soutien logistique et
opérationnel à l'Arménie.
Nous savons que, désormais, elle
se trouve sur la route d'une
attaque.
Nous voulons des interventions et
nous voulons sauver le peuple
arménien.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Catherine Colonna,
ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée Santiago, vous
avez raison, l'opération militaire
engagée par l'Azerbaïdjan il y a
quelques jours est injustifiable
et inacceptable.
La France l'a condamnée et elle
l'a condamnée à nouveau lors d'une
réunion au Conseil de sécurité il
y a quelques jours.
Nous voyons aujourd'hui les
conséquences de cette offensive.
L'Azerbaïdjan porte la
responsabilité du sort des
populations arméniennes du
Haut-Karabakh.
Notre position est claire.
Nous y travaillons avec nos
partenaires et alliés.
Aucune paix durable ne pourra être
atteinte dans le Caucase par la
force ou par la menace de la
force.
Nous sommes mobilisés jusqu'au
plus haut niveau et la France, je
le redis, s'engage avec ses
partenaires européens et
américains afin de parvenir à une
paix négociée juste et
respectueuse du droit
international.
Ce ne sera possible que si
certaines conditions sont
respectées.
Nous demandons le libre accès
humanitaire et la garantie pour la
population arménienne de pouvoir
continuer à vivre en paix et en
sécurité, dans le respect de leur
sécurité et de leur culture.
Pour ce qui concerne l'Arménie,
nous voulons le plein respect de
l'intégrité territoriale de ce
pays.
Nous souhaitons la délimitation
territoriale, le retrait des armes
de l'Azerbaïdjan.
Je rappelle que ces missions
d'opération européennes, elles ont
lieu grâce à la France.
Nous voulons amplifier notre aide
humanitaire.
Elle a plus que doublé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Emmanuelle
Anthoine pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Emmanuelle Anthoine: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Le 19 septembre dernier,
l'Azerbaïdjan a attaqué les
Arméniens du Haut-Karabakh.
Cette agression se fait au mépris
du droit international et vise à
imposer la loi du plus fort.
Elle intervient après neuf mois
d'un blocus qui a privé de
nourriture, de soins et
d'éducation les 120.000 habitants
de ce territoire, dont 30.000
enfants.
Après avoir provoqué une grave
crise humanitaire, l'Azerbaïdjan a
précipité le Haut-Karabakh dans
l'abîme de la guerre.
Plus de 200 personnes tuées et 400
blessés sont à déplorer.
Le peuple arménien, peuple martyr,
paye une fois de plus le prix du
sang en étant victime d'injustice
géopolitique.
Il y a un sentiment d'abandon des
Arméniens du Haut-Karabakh.
Il est à la hauteur de leur
dénuement.
Ils sont contraints à l'exode.
Plus de 13.000 réfugiés sont
arrivés en Arménie.
Ils ont laissé tous leurs biens,
toute leur vie, toute leur
histoire derrière eux.
C'est une culture multiséculaire
qui est sur le point d'être
effacée.
La destruction des traces de la
culture arménienne a déjà commencé
avec la destruction d'églises.
La crainte d'un nettoyage ethnique
ou culturel est plus forte que
jamais.
Nous devons accorder des garanties
de production aux Arméniens du
Haut-Karabakh.
L'inaction coupable de la
communauté internationale a permis
le drame qui se joue aujourd'hui
dans le Caucase.
Au-delà des paroles, il faut des
actes.
L'Azerbaïdjan pourrait ne pas
s'arrêter là et poursuivre ses
attaques contre l'Arménie.
Madame la ministre, la France
va-t-elle organiser l'envoi d'une
mission internationale
particulièrement nécessaire pour
garantir la sécurité des Arméniens
du Haut-Karabakh?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Catherine
Colonna, ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères.
- Catherine Colonna: Merci.
Madame la députée, je vous
remercie de votre question qui
m'offre l'occasion de compléter ma
réponse précédente.
Aucun pays n'aide davantage
l'Arménie que notre pays.
Vous le savez très bien.
C'est vrai sur le plan
diplomatique.
Toutes les réunions du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations Unies, sans
exception, se sont tenues à
l'initiative de la France.
C'est également, je le disais, à
l'initiative de la France qu'une
mission d'observation est déployée
en Arménie.
C'est vrai aussi sur le plan
humanitaire.
Mon ministère a déployé depuis le
début de l'année plus de 5
millions d'euros en faveur de
l'Arménie et des populations
arméniennes du Haut-Karabakh.
J'ai décidé, au vu des événements
des derniers jours, de porter
cette aide beaucoup plus haut,
avec 7 millions d'euros
supplémentaires.
Nous avons également renforcé
notre relation de défense avec
l'Arménie.
Puisque vous demandez des actes,
les voici.
L'attaché de défense sera présent
à l'ambassade de France à Erevan.
Nous ouvrirons prochainement une
antenne consulaire dans la région
qui se situe près de la frontière.
Ce sont des preuves tangibles, je
crois, de la présence déterminée
de la France aux côtés de
l'Arménie.
L'abandon de l'Arménie par la
Russie et la complicité de la
Russie avec les opérations
militaires organisées par
l'Azerbaïdjan rendent nécessaire
une action diplomatique
internationale.
Nous souhaitons aider l'Europe.
Elle doit prendre acte de cette
réalité.
Elle doit agir avec nous pour le
respect de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Arménie et pour
préserver le droit des Arméniens
du Haut-Karabakh à vivre dans le
respect de leurs droits
historiques.
Voilà ce que nous faisons.
Merci d'encourager la diplomatie
française à le faire plus encore.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, madame la ministre.
La séance est suspendue.